I wonder you feel the kind of person who
adored maths as a teenager now if you
did you probably know this already you
were very much in the minority that was
experience for teacher Eddie whoo
picture him year 10 it wasn't so much
that he didn't like math it just didn't
come that naturally to him he just
didn't really understand why it all
mattered you know why do any of these
numbers matter that was his question to
his teachers now as somewhat as a result
of his curiosity and his natural-born
communication skills
Eddie Wu did fall in love with maths and
went on to be both a math teacher and an
internet sensation
it's his care for his teachers his
desire to make a difference in the world
and his tech know-how that saw him
setting up a little channel called Wu
tube which is literally changing the
experience of math education for
thousands of teenagers and that the
story being told tonight thanks to
Australian story on the ABC at 8 p.m.
Eddie whoo welcome to afternoons it's
great to be here clear maths didn't come
easily to you tell me about the moment
that you got it for me I think I was
trying to actually wrap my head around
how to explain a mathematical concept
when I had enrolled at University to be
a teacher and we all had assignments to
say okay you have to deliver you know a
pretend lesson to your client to toriel
at school at university I thought okay
well I better wrap my head around this
so I can explain it and I went back and
I thought how hard can this be
I went to school I learned this stuff
and you know much to my horror I opened
up to the page that I was supposed to
talk through and just my mind just went
blank I thought okay I'm going to have
to start from scratch when you go back
to square one
and try and understand this idea from
the beginning try and understand why on
earth like is this in the syllabus for a
reason or just someone edged in stone
once upon a time at the top of a
mountain no all students must learn this
ok look I'm going to do my research and
it was a it was a concept called first
principles in a topic called calculus
which I had done at school and I sort of
could answer the questions but just
never comprehended until that moment
where I forced myself to explain it to
my
to my own fellow university students and
that's where I realized oh wait okay if
you ask the question of mass why is this
important what does it speak to me about
the world not just how do I answer the
question then actually it speaks really
deeply to that human desire to
understand the world around you and be
able to appreciate what makes it work
anyone who's watched your woo tube
channel
knows that one of the skills that you
have is is yes making meaning out of
these things that well we don't
necessarily understand their practical
application very often in your classes
we can hear the sounds of students going
I can't it we can hear laughter and
communication you're the co head of
mathematics now at cherrybrook Technical
High School and you know as someone who
loves those students who don't quite get
it for you however the satisfaction of
being a teacher well it wasn't what your
parents thought you would do with your
life was it no they were quite surprised
I think honestly taken aback for you
know the news that I told them when you
know I want to do education I'm
interested in working in a school in our
country Australia you know teachers are
not exactly held in very high regard and
a huge amount of money either and so
when they heard me say this there was
very much a sense of but you know there
are things you could do where you could
earn loads more money and you could have
higher status like why would you choose
this and familiar your parents are
migrants from Malaysia and they had
sacrificed a lot to kind of get you guys
over here and I knew that you could
speak many many languages and you tell
the story in Australia story of your
mother had some wishes for you yeah she
definitely came from a very well-off
background so it was um I think
compounded the fact that you know any
migrant not just from an Asian
background I remember I met a friend
from Union he was Hungarian and he said
to me oh yeah yeah yeah that's my
parents too at a they've just given up
so very much to come here and you know
raise a family with very little support
even understanding of the language here
in Australia and you know they did that
so that we could have
a better life so that we can have access
to education that would open doors that
we would never have had access to if
we'd been born back where we came from
and so in addition to that my one my mom
coming from a very well-off background
and you know having quite a bit of
privilege where she came from I think it
was quite shocking and she spent months
and months trying to argue me out of
becoming a teacher and it was very
difficult for her
I was quite sad because she actually
passed away my first University while we
still we never really saw eye to eye and
so it's a bit bittersweet knowing that
you know now I've come this far and I
would have loved for her to have seen it
but I hope you know my dad I'm very
lucky he's very proud of what I've
achieved and so I hoped that she would
be to look on tonight Australian story
New South Wales Department of Education
Secretary Mark Scott says that you're
the kind of teacher he would like to
clone so I have absolutely no doubt you
your mother would be enormous ly proud
of what you've done
this theme of your mother passed away
understand Eddie from cancer and this
theme of cancer was actually the genesis
of what started were tube tell us about
that one student that you were trying to
get through to when he first started
recording your maths lessons it was all
the way back in 2012 and I had a student
in my class and he was diagnosed with
cancer which is just I mean I was I was
shattered when my mum was diagnosed with
cancer to hear that news of yourself
when you're meant to have your entire
life out in front of you I just couldn't
imagine how difficult an experience he
was going through but what I could
imagine and what I knew was coming for
him was that his whole life was about to
be turned upside down and it was he
spent weeks at a time in treatment and
of course you know for any cancer
treatment just kind of wreaked havoc
with your immune system and so there was
so much time that he lost from school I
thought he's not going to be able to
make it he's going to come back to
school we're going to get him for a few
weeks here or there but a lot of people
will have had that experience where
something in mathematics didn't click
and then when you came back the next
time to try and let it you're like one
what even is all of this stuff I don't I
can't
pieced together everything it's like
trying to do a jigsaw puzzle which you
have all the pieces which is the point
so many of our listeners I know would
have given up on math absolutely and I
can I can understand that it's a very I
mean high schools challenging for
everyone you're going through intense
changes a person and lots of emotions
swirling around your life is busy so I
understand why you know the wheels fall
off for people and they never quite you
know to be metaphors they never quite
get back on the horse to understand
mathematics and I did what this happened
to this students so I thought you know
what this is not going to look crash hot
but it'll it'll do I'm just going to get
my phone I put it up on top of a table
in my classroom and you could see the
whiteboard you can hear my voice as I
explained concepts and I just sent him I
sent the whole class actually cuz I
didn't want to single him out I sent
them all links to the videos as they
went up so that if there was a concept
that they'd missed or that they just
wanted a bit of revision on they could
go back at any time they could watch
rewatch stop skip anything they wanted
and for him that was just you know it
wasn't the same of course as being in
the classroom but it kind of tied it a
move on and it helps him to still be a
part of the class and share that
learning experience with us and once the
videos were there other people found out
about it and it just sort of took on a
life of its own your channel has now had
over two-and-a-half million views in
fact what sort of stories do you get
back from students from overseas or
places in Australia where you've never
visited about what maths means to them
now for me it's been quite a opening to
hear from such a variety of people some
of whom as you put out are in other
countries some of whom have left high
school long long ago and honestly I have
no idea how they stumbled on my videos
but I think they and I have been
pleasantly surprised by the fact that
you know a lot of people feel like they
don't like maths because there was some
point of which they didn't comprehend it
and it just sort of became a difficult
experience for them but these people
who've been going onto the channel have
found actually there's nothing about
maths that's inherently in
or scary or impossible to learn everyone
just needs a different kind of
explanation and it seems like the stuff
that I've been putting a lot online has
really been you know scratching an itch
still a lot of people have it in
language that's easy to understand
because like I mentioned before stuff
doesn't come naturally to me so I have
to get it down to something that's
simple and easy to understand and if I
can pass that on to people around the
world I just it's the icing on the cake
really we're speaking with Rockstar math
teacher Eddie whoo otherwise known as
mr. woo tube on his website and on
Instagram and so on but he is changing
the face of math teaching he's using
technology to do that and he's someone
who is setting a new standard when it
comes to teaching something of interest
attaching meaning to Education and Eddie
I can't think of a quality that we
really want more of when it comes to
teaching you know you share with many
great barristers throughout history and
actors and so on this this ability to
perform and to bring passion to what you
do how important do you think that is to
your communication of maths and its
meanings look it's amazing actually that
when I studied for years of drama in
high school from year 9 to 12 I actually
did that because I was terrified of
public speaking and standing up in front
of people I would just you know that
that ball would grow in my stomach and
I'd start my hand to start shaking and
so for me that was just a way to
overcome you know that that sort of
fright and anxiety because communication
it matters things of importance are
often missed because we don't
communicate them properly even though
they are important so I think in some
ways you know it's it's at the heart of
what makes my lessons work and what
brings students along with me I like to
think that if I can bring my a-game and
my enthusiasm and energy to the
classroom no matter what kind of day a
student is having you can't help but be
sort of brought along for the experience
and so I think that you know it's part
of what makes mathematics you know it's
not that it's scary or or impossible to
understand but if it's in an exciting
and entertaining and
engaging way and shown in a way that you
know I really want my students
understand a lot of the things that
people said to me that was a really
helpful explanation I didn't think about
them in a premeditated way I was just in
the classroom and I saw that glazed look
over my students eyes and my my
explanation that I prepared didn't you
know land with them so I had to think of
something new and or you know being up
on stage and improvising that's one of
the key skills that you know an actor
has to have and that's become really
useful to me in the classroom Eddy if
you had to explain to me the rewards of
Maps what's something you would tell me
because I might still be sitting here
thinking you know what's the point why
do I need math in my life you know I've
survived okay I've got a calculator what
am I missing out on I probably say two
things in answer to that question when
you're thinking about what am I missing
out on if I don't have that a real
mathematical understanding of things I
mean firstly yes you point out you do
have a calculator but I'll also like the
vision you have to use that calculator I
often tell my students a calculator is
just a tool for you to use it if you
don't know how to use it then it's just
going to be a tool and that's not very
helpful to anyone I've lost count of the
number of times that I've had to explain
to someone you know what if you add 10
percent to something because GST and
then you take ten percent off of it
because it's on sale or something like
that then it doesn't go back to its
original price it's something else it's
different it's actually cheaper than the
original and for to understand that as a
simple everyday mathematical numerical
reality yeah sure we have access to
technology week which makes things much
easier to calculate than ever before and
I'm not going to be upset with anyone if
they don't you know know their times
tables up to fifteen off by hi but you
know I like to say to my students
machines calculators computers they're
for answers humans are for questions you
know it's only going to be a person who
decides what's the important thing what
matters in this situation how are we
going to analyze the numbers here and
then I can tell a computer to do
whatever jobs necessary that's the first
thing just the fact that practically
speaking there's lots of numerical
reality all around us
secondly though I'd love to think that
anyone who understands mathematics in a
deeper way than just your basic plus
most plain plus minus times divide I get
a richer and a deeper understanding of
the world I mean I'll give you an
example if you pick up if you go for a
walk into a park and you pick up a
flower a flower is a beautiful object
everyone could agree on that but it's
also an intensely mathematical object
like if you can just picture in your
mind say a sunflower you know you've got
that that tall stalk and then right at
the top you've got that those brilliant
yellow bright orange leaves and in the
middle you got all these sort of seeds
floret that are erasing this very
distinctive pattern there kind of spiral
what is it that makes that shape the way
it is and actually this is beautiful
piece of mathematics called the golden
ratio that explains exactly why they are
in that perfect chain and why that makes
so much sense for a flower now do you
need to know that well no you don't but
once you do grasp your put your mind
around a crazy concept like that it
allows you to look at the world through
new eyes I mean I I'm very short sighted
and I've got quite poor vision and when
I put glasses on I can see the world
around me in a whole new way and I think
of mathematics a bit like that pair of
glasses
thanks to this Australian story that
will be viewing tonight you're about to
get a whole lot of extra attention as if
you didn't have enough already you know
we've got your 38,000 subscribers on
YouTube and I said two and a half
million you actually really close it a
four million views now my research is
updated as we've been chatting Eddy if I
gave you a magic wand and allowed you to
wave it in whichever way you like
tonight what is it that you would like
educationalists to know about improving
Australia's education system what is it
that we could be doing to support our
teachers and support our students Wow if
you gave me a magic wand I would look at
her for a long time and think because
there's so many things that need to be
done honestly in order to change the
situation that we're in
if I had to pick out just one I think it
would be I want everyone in education
and even you know parents and children
young children to understand we need
particularly in the math field we need
the absolute best people we can standing
in our classrooms you know nearly on the
ground beside our kids in here for
standing up the front of the class
helping the attends who've been doing
mathematics for 11 years because they've
been forced to to help them understand
in a dynamic way
what is mathematics why is it important
how can I make sense of it how can i
connect it to what my life is now which
is different to the person sitting next
to me and it's different to what it was
10 years ago
we need the absolute best people who
have mathematical understanding who have
a passion for kids and helping them grow
as people we need them in our classrooms
and time and time again I see amazing
people with huge amounts of talent and
they look at education and teaching as
if well that's you know those who can do
and those who can't teach and that's
just such a tragedy and so many problems
unfold from that you know millions of
dollars are being poured into you know
national programs for increasing amount
of stem participation among students
across the country I federally we
understand that it's a big issue what we
really need is the teachers on the
ground to be able to convey to our
students you know what mathematics it
has for everyone and that understanding
of it's going to help all of us in
society no matter whether you're an
actuary an engineer or a business owner
or a chef wherever you're going to be
mathematics could help you do that
better and that's what I wish everyone
understood
Eddie Wu you're a gift to us thank you
so much it's a pleasure class thanks so
much for your time
Eddie Wu co-head of mathematics at
cherrybrook Technical High School also
runs the very popular Wu tube you can
find him at mr. Wu tube or on his
website at the similar name and his
story will be told tonight an Australian
story that's Monday
first of May today 8 p.m. on ABC and ABC
iView I think you're gonna love it